pesquisadores da Universidade da
Califórnia fizeram um estudo
impressionante. Eles pegaram dois
suplementos super simples, vitamina B de
bola 3 que você encontra em qualquer
farmácia e o EGCG, epigalato, catequin
galato, que é aquele antioxidante do
chete, e testaram nos neurônios. Em
apenas 16 horas, essa dupla conseguiu
rejuvenecer células cerebrais
envelhecidas, fazendo elas funcionarem
como se fossem jovens de novo. Veja bem,
o que acontece é o seguinte. Conforme a
gente envelhece, nossos neurônios vão
perder energia, especialmente uma
molécula chamada GTP. É como se fosse a
bateria do celular que vai ficando
viciada. Sem essa energia, o cérebro não
consegue fazer a faxina celular. Aí
acumula lixo tóxico, aquelas proteínas
betamide que causam Alzheimer, a
vitamina B3 com egcg restauraram
completamente essa energia, reativaram o
sistema de limpeza ainda reduziram em
22% a morte dos neurônios. Então fica a
dica. Que tal começar a tomar aquele chá
verde todo dia e conversar com o seu
profissional de saúde sobre
suplementação de vitamina B de bola 3?
Yeah.